president Trump's lawyers reportedly
received several questions that special
counsel robert muller wants to ask the
president the questions first revealed
by the new york times center on whether
the president obstructed justice in
connection with former national security
adviser michael Flynn former FBI
director James Comey and Attorney
General Jeff Sessions other questions
focus on the Trump campaigns contacts
with Russia Jeff Pegues is outside the
special counsels office in Washington
Jeff good morning good morning there are
44 questions according to the New York
Times that special counsel Robert Muller
wants the President to answer setting up
a dramatic showdown if this meeting
actually happens Muller steam has
informed the president's attorneys that
he is not a target of the Russian
investigation but these questions
suggest that they are interested in the
president's actions many of the
questions special counsel Muller wants
to ask the president involve former FBI
director James Comey the New York Times
reports what did you think about mr.
commis intelligence briefing on January
6th 2017 about Russian election
interference and regarding the decision
to fire mr. Comey when was it made why
and who played a role do you look at all
of the people on the Democratic side not
only the Republican side that was saying
such terrible things about director
Comey Muller also wants to ask the
president about his May 12th tweet when
he wrote James Comey better hope that
there are no tapes of our conversations
before he starts leaking to the press
Laurie I hope their tapes president
Trump's decision to fire Comey led to
Muller's appointment as special counsel
the president says Muller's
investigation is a witch-hunt Muller
would also like to ask the president
about former national security adviser
Michael Flynn who is now cooperating
with the special counsels investigation
I asked for his resignation he
respectfully gave it lynn was fired just
24 days into the Trump administration
for lying about his contacts with the
Russian ambassador Muller wants to know
what the president knew about those
calls why he decided to fire Flynn and
what efforts were made to reach out to
Flynn about a possible pardon Comey is
said President Trump asked him to drop
the Flynn investigation it was
increasingly concern in my part
I was interacting with him about things
that touched him personally that touched
the FBI and me our responsibilities and
that he might lie about them the Special
Counsel also wants to know if the
president asked Attorney General Jeff
Sessions to protect him the special
counsels office did not comment on this
list of questions the President did just
this morning he tweeted that it is
disgraceful that the questions were
leaked John Jeff Thanks